When it comes to finding a great conflict
to tell a compelling story, you don't get
much more classic than sibling rivalry.
“ahhh!”
Cain and Abel were brothers who got in a fight,
and settled their differences with a rock
to the head.
"I guess that settles it."
So it's no surprise that every movie in the
Thor franchise which depicts Norse gods smashing
monsters and each other with fists, hammers,
and anything else within arm's reach uses
sibling rivalry as a launching point in all
three installments.
The first two feature the conflict and subsequent
reconciliation between brothers Thor and Loki
as the most important features of their plots.
Meanwhile, Thor: Ragnarok takes things a step
further by introducing a third member of Odin's
brood, Hela, who takes over Asgard and motivates
her feuding younger brothers to work together
to defeat her.
But as Marvel Cinematic Universe fans have
since discovered, plans were underway behind
the scenes to give Thor and Loki yet another,
different sibling a brother who might be more
familiar to comic book readers and lovers
of Norse mythology.
That's right, Balder the Brave was almost
introduced to the MCU to further complicate
Thor's family tree.
Former Marvel Studios head of visual development
Charlie Wen sent MCU fans into a frenzy back
in August 2018 with a single Instagram post.
Wen posted concept art for Thor: The Dark
World that revealed his take on adapting longtime
Thor comics character Balder to the big screen.
While the character's inclusion in the film
was eventually scuttled, it's exciting to
imagine how the MCU might've been different
had Balder survived pre-production.
So what's the big deal about Balder?
Well, for starters, he's got more right to
the throne than either Thor or Loki at least
if Marvel Comics and Norse mythology have
anything to say about it.
The films depict Frigga, played by Rene Russo,
as Thor's mother.
But outside of the films, it's Gaea, the Earth
goddess, who is Thor's real mom, while Frigga
is actually his step-mother.
Wen explained the character's importance during
our exclusive interview:
"Odin was doing something on the side that
he shouldn't have and then he brought Thor
baby Thor back and Frigga, and Odin brought
Thor up.
In a way it's like Balder is really the true
heir to throne, if you really want to put
it that way.
There's a lot of things about that character
that can be really key to the story."
However, the filmmakers behind the MCU know
when to stay faithful to the comics, and when
to streamline and simplify in order to keep
the average moviegoer interested.
It's one of the reasons the MCU works as well
as it does and introducing Balder to the mix
in The Dark World would've made a mess of
an already pretty complicated story one featuring
spacefaring Dark Elves, a reality-warping
Infinity Stone, and Kat Dennings.
Do you even know what these things do?"
"No."
"Neither do I."
How could Balder compete with all that?
"It makes a lot of sense not trying to force
him in because he complicates things quite
a bit.
Especially if you're trying to make a story
really about Thor and Loki."
But while Wen and the rest of the production
team tried to bring Balder into the fold,
ultimately the biggest hurdle was just that
there was no easy way to introduce the character
into the MCU's increasingly complex continuity.
At least, there weren't any that also gave
him the importance the comics says he should
have.
“In the comics, he is the one that's supposed
to be able to... he triggers Ragnarok.
He's the one that actually triggers that whole
event of the destruction of Asgard.
He's an important character in the comics.
How do you integrate him without him feeling
like he's just an added character, right?
I think that ultimately, not having him in
Thor 1 or 2 makes sense."
Wen left Marvel Studios to pursue his own
creative endeavors in 2014, so he's not involved
in the future of the MCU at least not directly.
But as it turns out, much of the design work
he did at the company still pops up in Marvel
movies so many years later.
So, despite the fact that we've yet to see
Balder appear in the MCU to this point doesn't
mean Wen's designs won't make it onto the
big screen sometime in the future.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more exclusive Looper videos with
Charlie Wen about the creation of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.